what do you insecure about what am i
insecure about yeah is there anything
cuz you know I would think you've had
some success you saw audio what am I one
of myself about that
well like you a squeaky voice in a big
ass one out of two ain't bad I got to
tell you I have a squeaky voice and
absolutely no ass and and Oh what I
wouldn't do for absolutely the in a in a
I would love to have the absolutely no
ass I have wronged my ass it just it
goes in it when others are a little out
its concave it caught it's concave and I
I can keep little figurines in there say
yeah so they're changers took your
wallet and got a glass of water in there
at all times I can whip it out yeah god
I've got I've got a but but if I have
like three Oreos it just expands before
your very eyes the worst thing is the
squeaky voice yeah I hate my voice and
would you get excited like this will the
reason I don't like to get mad because
when I do it always just let me get this
straight we come off like I'm you know
getting hassled on the bus on the way to
junior high school hey guys come on
that's my lunch money
[Laughter]